[Music]
iconic nba star bill russell has died
he was 88 years old
i never felt like i was making the
contribution
i was just doing the best i could
bill's family shared the news to social
media
in a statement they revealed he died
peacefully on sunday with wife janine at
his side
no cause of death is known at this time
bill's one of the most celebrated
figures in sports history he was an 11
time nba champion he led the usa's gold
medal winning basketball team at the
1956 olympics
as a player bill's entire nba career was
with the boston celtics
later making history with his last two
seasons on the court
while both coaching and playing bill
became the first blackhead coach of any
northern american professional sports
team
the nba community took to social media
with tributes magic johnson wrote on
twitter quote bill russell was my idol
and noted quote off the court bill
russell paved the way for guys like me
dwayne wade shared this photo to his
instagram story calling bill a quote
pioneer
former president barack obama tweeted
quote today we lost a giant as tall as
bill russell stood his legacy rises far
higher both as a player and as a person
obama previously honored bill with the
presidential medal of freedom in 2011.
this year's medal of freedom recipients
reveal the best of who we are
and who we aspire to be more than any
athlete of his era bill russell came to
define the word winner he made a point
to reflect on bill's work as a civil
rights advocate
he marched with king
he stood by ali
when a restaurant refused to serve the
black celtics he refused to play in the
scheduled game
he endured insults and vandalism but he
kept on focusing on making the team
teammates who he loved
better players
and made possible the success of so many
who would follow
you